[Music]
well
have you guys been wondering what billy
mcfarlane has been up to not at all who
is that
not at all the guy who did firefest wait
the guy that was going to suck the dick
no no no no no that's a lawyer that's
the one i care about true
but i was going to suck some [ __ ]
he is currently serving six
years good in federal prison
[Music]
really i don't think it i think look
they get the laurie laughlin girl who
got like what a
month oh yeah a month this guy's getting
six years well she probably had the
this guy's trying to throw a party it's
at a good time party
on an island she's trying to buy an
education he also
he stole money yeah he stole money he
lied to investors
he actually owes 26 mil in restitution
how can you pay that back
that's more than i thought you can't pay
that back while you're in jail wow
well that's the reason why he's in the
news now because in an attempt
to pay off this restitution
he decided to start a podcast oh [ __ ]
prison oh wow how do you do that yeah so
he recorded an entire podcast via 15
minute phone conversations
with jordan harbinger do you know who he
is yeah
he's a very prominent podcaster
harbinger harbinger
i don't know i don't have no idea but
what about this person
can we cut that we'll cut that oh wait
no you're right
you're right you're right cut mine cut
mine out guys we're recording a podcast
here
no cut mine no yours is correct put my
anyway [ __ ] i wasn't paying attention
and i came in and i'm [ __ ] lost
harbinger
yo that's my shtick geo
gonna take that from you no but you do
you're not paying attention but you pay
attention that's your thing
oh i guess ah dude i don't know what's
going on what are we talking about
we're just taking too damn long to get
to the story well i've been telling you
the story
i'm a prison podcast i find that very
fascinating podcast so he's calling it
dumpster fire
that's pretty cool okay that's pretty
cool he's sticking to his guns with the
whole branding thing
you can get guests by talking into the
toilet
it's like telephone like that the yeah
how is he going to get guests they have
to commit a crime to get into
the [ __ ] well they have to come to
that phone thing on the glass
and my next guest is well at least
they're practicing
like covet rules right social difference
with the pexy
all right i'm gonna play the trailer to
his podcast okay
this is excellent promotion this is
crazy how is he getting it all this is a
little
orange [ __ ] thing that's insane
oh my god you got drone shots and [ __ ]
wow
that's him on the phone otherwise known
as
billy the founder of fire festival
this guy's nonstop
[Music]
that was really good he knows how to
hype that makes me want to watch it
what's your [ __ ] excuse at home
you're not doing
this producing a documentary did you
guys see the photos
of him in prison him and his friends the
yard
i mean he's probably having a good time
he's tall that's a photo from the early
90s
well they're actually produced with the
with the disposable cameras
wow inmates are allowed to take pictures
uh disposable cameras and then they just
get screened before they get sent out
so you could take photos they all smell
like butthole a little bit probably how
do they get them in there i know right
well the prison gives it to them or
maybe they buy them i don't know
something like that but yeah it's
provided by the prison i heard that
prison isn't bad when you have money
because you just pay all the different
gangs to not [ __ ] with you
like if you pay all their leaders and
stuff it's kind of like yeah and then
you can also like pay for like
servants and all this stuff and i'm like
damn that's pretty cool wow
heard from a former drug cartel guy on a
podcast
he was like he was like prison's not bad
if you're rich he's like and you're
connected and he goes yeah he's like
you just have a lot of money he's like
no one's going to mess with you
because someone like me who's not
[ __ ] street smart uh
i would have the [ __ ] most horrible
time but you're not rich and organized
or connected so do you think that if if
he was on family or
full house he probably wouldn't have got
such a bad sentence
um yeah he wasn't a likable figure
on tv before she was like a member of my
family
um becky are you talking about because
of the university fraud yeah yeah the
laura laughing thing he brought up
oh yeah she has she had actual jail time
i never liked her on full house she's
the aunt you wanted to have sex with
you didn't want to [ __ ] her that hard no
i like the what's that what was her
man's name
uncle jesse uncle jesse john stamos
he's the one that survived where
everyone knows his name it's damos
well who was the other guy well the main
guy
guy joey gladstone yeah
i'm blanking on the main guy brady
tanner
but what's yeah what's his real name
dave cool is his name he's not bob sage
no bob sag it's danny tanner yeah yeah
yeah
wait who's dave cooley what the [ __ ]
we're doing it again
yeah cut it out he's the guy who did the
spin-off
i'm sorry where are we right here fire
festival guys doing a podcast farland
this is where we're at
so because of this announcement of his
prison podcast he actually got
solitary confinement 23 hour a day
solitary confinement for
this release of his podcast how does he
put out a sizzle
for his podcast without the prison
knowing that's exactly what
billy's lawyer is is arguing here
because it's like they
fully knew what the [ __ ] was happening
they knew the production of this podcast
it's [ __ ] up that he's in solitary
confinement right now and he could be
held up there
for up to 90 days or more so they're
like oh [ __ ] we look bad why did we do
this we thought it would be cool and
then it like
he's just getting more content in there
now he's got a recorder in there
he's he's a banking episode it's just
all dark
now he has 23 hours of just talking
the prison that he's at is declining to
comment so we don't know what the
prison's reason is
but we just found out because of the
lawyer he's
telling media that he's in solitary
confinement right now
and this is actually the second time he
has solitary confinement
first time he had it for three months
because the prison discovered
a he was in a in possession of a usb
drive and during that first solitary
confinement stint is when he came up
with the idea of
doing this podcast how do you even pay
back 26 million
right what if you're the guy that has to
smuggle the shure sm7b mic
into the prison up your ass
big [ __ ] mic he needs good sound
quality all right
because he does high production [ __ ]
he's not going to settle for like he's
not going to use a yeti
no he's doing it through the phone it
sounds more like raw the way the [ __ ]
tick tockers do it right now with the
[ __ ] apple
headphones the janet jackson performance
one or the tiny little mic
the usb how is the show do we like the
show is it good i was listening to it
last night and
the first 20 minutes it was just
repeating the same [ __ ] is how many
episodes are out
uh as of now two episodes what's he
talking about he's like yeah i did fire
fest
yeah so i broke my balls 20 because i
only heard 20 minutes of it it's a whole
hour
um and in that first 20 minutes he was
just fully being like
yes i [ __ ] up i there's no excuse
i'm paying for for my crimes and
i hurt a lot of people i deceived a lot
of people i just thought that i could
get myself out of the hole and i just
kept digging in deeper
and and then yeah so then jordan the
podcast dude he ends up asking him like
why did you continue this festival if
you already knew that it was gonna be a
complete
disaster and he was like well i've been
throwing events since
in the past he had these other like uh
startup companies where he would throw
like exclusive new york
parties and so he did one called the 911
attacks
really it was oh
i'm like he's really stupid it was gonna
be a good party i thought
damn no but yeah so he was saying like
by throwing those events he's already
got
gotten desensitized to all these
problems because it's such a small scale
because yeah and then but he's just like
every time a problem
would come forward i would solve it but
then like three more three more would
sprout or whatever it is
it's a big [ __ ] operation yes it's
not like a networking event
exactly so he he just thought he could
manage it and he can handle it he
thought he was a [ __ ] he
admits he had like a huge ego about it
and
now he's just so a 100 of the proceeds
of this podcast is going to be going to
that 26 mil that i
mentioned earlier and that's what he's
he continuously mentioned
in the podcast because jordan is like
why should we trust you why should we
listen why do we give a [ __ ] what you're
saying
and he's just like listen i'm just
trying to be 100 transparent
what happened throughout this entire
event i want to just throw it all out
there
every obstacle i faced i want the world
to know what happened and i wanted them
to learn from my bad mistakes
and also you're my co-host jordan like
take it easy
whoa jordan coming in hot bro no he
actually tells him like i want you to
like go in on me like [ __ ] just ask
me whatever
you need to ask me like he's actually he
seems pretty open to like
what companies are you doing his ad
reads on i know right he's at
guttable.com
it's probably a cup of noodles you know
that's a pretty high quality
cigarettes yes cigarettes marble
lights and red but yeah and then the
guests that you guys were talking about
it's gonna be people from his team or
people that
they're locked up with them by no that
were affected
by his lies like people like he brought
it or whatever oh he's got a lot of
those so he could really get he could
get some years out of this thing
he [ __ ] so many people here wow yep
well good for him huh
yeah i guess what uh i'm gonna make
lemonade you know
i wonder he's gonna come up with noah
out of the second solitary confinement
we got mini fire fest uh one time
and it was crazy how this kid pulled it
off he never threw an event before
but he somehow got us
tim dumbfounded a bunch of other
musicians and youtubers at the time eric
too
eric superego yeah yeah and somehow
he got us to come in without any pay
he booked a venue at a high school he
didn't
he was he was basically just banking on
the audience to
to come in and pay the ax but since
we found out that other people were
gonna do it too we're just like oh
you're going to that event okay well i
guess i gotta go
and then we're like this this seems kind
of weird but they weren't gonna pay us a
booking fee or whatever until after
we're like [ __ ] it let's just do it
they're doing it it seems pretty legit
and these other people also didn't get
paid up front no one got paid because
somehow everyone was like oh wait you
you're doing the thing okay we'll do it
too right
so it was like a fire fest situation and
we always like seeing each other at
events or like yeah
let's just do it we'll be there yeah
when we get there it's just uh
he didn't even research the weather or
he just didn't plan anything yeah
it was raining yeah outdoors it was
outdoors
had a [ __ ] little corner area
he didn't promote it i mean no one
showed up because he just assumed that
because we're coming millions of people
will show up and pay
he didn't have anything ready and he was
just some high school kid and i was like
mind blown i was like
that's how vidcon started that's how all
these things started there was one of
these that happened as like a youtuber
festivals attract like the biggest con
men right
they try and like put it together and
like because they get the money up front
one and done it's over in a weekend and
then they're gone
and then they set up another one there's
one of these in australia that they were
doing for
youtubers i remember that and like i i
remember being like i like
don't know this guy doesn't seem like he
has any experience i didn't participate
in it but like
i know people that did the whole thing
like was a complete mess
it was like tanacon or one yeah it was
just one of these
complete just money grabs and ja
rule walks free to this day yeah so no
[ __ ]
and he's doing mexican restaurant
commercials
oh that's right i saw that no it wasn't
mexican it was a different
it's okay there's like indian food or
something mediterranean mediterranean
it's raining oh i thought it was tacos
but he was like i [ __ ] love this food
that's enough to get me to go honestly
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
foreign